first question just curious how this
whole alphabet situation has changed
your job and your approach at Google
Ventures well thanks I'm really good too
it's really business as usual for us
we've always operated independently made
our own investment decisions and invest
it apart from Google's product roadmap
so not much has changed for us so you
had a role in the formation of Calico
which is Google's efforts to extend our
lifespan what are some concrete examples
of progress there and opportunities you
see to really extend our lives I think
the opportunity in the life sciences is
really hard to understate at this point
in time I think the change that we're
gonna see between now and the next 20
years is going to be similar to what
we've seen happen in communications over
the last 20 years where you can talk to
anyone anywhere anytime by video
essentially for free and 20 years ago
you would write a letter and that's a
pretty big change and I think we're
gonna see a similar change enabled by
computational capabilities over the next
20 years in healthcare and I'm really
excited about it
so let's talk about investment
opportunities I mean give us some
specifics what are the most interesting
and exciting opportunities you see out
there right now why we look at the
healthcare ecosystem as a as a continuum
so so there's Diagnostics there's
therapeutics
there's payer systems there's devices so
there's a lot of different areas in
healthcare and when you apply machine
learning and and new technology to each
of those areas there's some pretty
exciting opportunities and just to give
you one example
Eddy toss is a company we've invested in
in the gene editing space which is
something that would have been hard to
even imagine 15 years ago as a company
but it holds great promise to hopefully
treat a number of diseases that are
really untreatable right now now I know
this idea of immortality is very
fascinating to
I was recently speaking with Sebastian
throng the founder of Google X about the
same thing and he said that he thinks
that we will significantly be able to
extend our lives in our lifetime and and
the question is is really why don't
humans live to two hundred years I mean
how far along are are we in that process
bill I mean are we really gonna see an
additional 10 20 years added to our
lives in our lifetime what was really
careful to talk about that because when
we say in our lifetime none of us really
know what our lifetime is you know I
could I could say yes and walk outside
and get hit by a bus I mean these things
happen but I think in a reasonable
amount of time I think we can see real
improvements in treating a number of
diseases and I think to talk about
immortality is a is a good way to kind
of take it to its extreme but we're
talking about the realities of science
and and I think when we think about that
we have to think about the fact that we
have the ability to extend life right
now so if we just a lot of people
talking about the redistribution of
wealth and I like to think about the
redistribution of health and so when I
think about that the average lifespan in
the u.s. is something like 70 to 80
years but in western Africa it's about
40 we have the ability right now with
our existing technology to extend life
it's just a matter of do we have the
commitment to really see it through and
globally and not just in this country
now I want to talk about your opinion on
on fairness and Elizabeth Holmes you
recently told Business Insider we looked
at their notes a couple of times but
there was so much hand waving like look
over here that you know we just couldn't
figure it out so we had someone from our
life science investment team go into
Walgreens take the test and it wasn't
that difficult for anyone to determine
that things may not be what they seemed
here now she responded to you at the
Wall Street Journal conference saying
he's never met with us he's never
reached out to us if he just wants to
talk badly about us he's free to talk
badly about us it's a free country what
really happened
well I think the first part of what you
said is exactly true we had someone from
our team go and take the test and
instead of one vial of water one nano
container of blood to turn into five
with the follow-up call several days
later looking for even more blood and it
just was apparent that if things were
not what they seems and and I think it's
really important because when you're
dealing in the life sciences you're
dealing with a really vulnerable
population of people patients that are
banking on some of the promises of this
new technology so I have to be really
careful about the claims that you make
and I think in this case what's been
written about the company and what's
been what is being written I think
speaks for itself
you know obviously if if what she's
saying is possible really is possible
that's amazing but it is really scary to
me that a company could raise money at a
ten billion dollar valuation if there
really isn't that much there I mean bill
what do you think actually happened here
do you think maybe they just got too far
ahead of themselves you know I read a
really interesting Cora answer to this
question just yesterday and I think what
happened I think there's a lot of
culpability and a lot of the media has
something to do with it getting carried
away with a story and not really looking
into the science I mean we've got life
science companies that we invest in
23andme is a great example they've
they've published over 40 peer review
articles on their science and no one's
ever questioned the accuracy of the data
that they're providing to consumers and
in this case with any of the data and
that's part of the problem and whatever
we would ask the media would ask
Elizabeth Holmes about the the data and
the technology they would say it was a
trade secret which makes me wonder why
so many magazines put her on the cover
of magnet put her on the cover and she's
on that board kind of on the board of
Fellows of Harvard Medical School from
what I understand and and
I don't know that any of those folks
have seen the science behind it because
there hasn't been a single peer-reviewed
journal article about it
now you're also an investor in in
23andme which just saw a pretty major
comeback after its own run-ins with the
FDA
I just yesterday sat down with Anne
Wojcicki and she talked about how far
they've come
take a listen I feel great like I am I'm
super proud of the company and what
we've accomplished because I think when
you have to slog through and you just
have to put your head down and know that
there's a lot of work ahead of you and
you're not gonna see a reward for a
couple years it's hard and you know we
had an incredible retention rate people
stay then people were determined and
they work through it and I think
actually even with the launch I almost
feel like that was just like we just
climbed the first flight of stairs but
we're still climbing the Empire State
Building so we just there's a lot more
to go and so for me part of what I think
about too is pacing is that we have it's
it's amazing we're back on the market we
have we have an incredible product we've
completely redesigned everything and
what I'm really excited about is that
this is the first chapter and a whole
new book for 23 me you're gonna see that
full interview on an upcoming episode of
studio 1.0 but bill how would you
compare 23m ease situation with the FDA
with what we're seeing with tharros and
what is your vision for the future of
this you know return the 23andme being
apart from the fact that they're both
companies I don't see much of a
similarity I mean 23andme has that team
has put their nose to the grindstone
over the last two years and worked
extremely hard with the FDA to get over
some regulatory hurdles to be able to
bring their product to market which is
really different from having the very
basis of the do you actually have a
product and does does it does it work
and is it accurate be questioned those
are two it's really different to try
something that's difficult and run into
roadblocks and work through them to
through to claims that you have
something and have no evidence that it
actually exists those are really
different situations now I want to talk
to you also about robotics and I
this is something else that you've had a
long-standing interest in are you still
seeing good opportunities out there or
have they all been bought by Google and
Facebook already you know I think the
question of AI and machine learning it's
it's not so much looking for general AI
companies to invest in for us that
artificial intelligence is it's all
around us it's on your phone your phone
helps you find where to go it can tell
you the weather or there there's
artificial intelligence in your car
there's there have been computer games
that can beat the greatest chess masters
in the world for many years so it's
around us it's a it's a layer on top of
a lot of the companies that we invest in
that are helping to accelerate some of
their innovations and we're seeing other
companies like uber for example become
more interested in in artificial
intelligence Google Ventures of course a
big investor in uber how much of Givi
success is predicated on that investment
and how complicated is it now that
Google obviously makes self-driving cars
and uber is working on its own
self-driving cars
why don't say our investment in uber
isn't successful yet the company is
still growing and faces hurdles and
challenges and so I'd be really careful
to say that that I don't think any
success that we might have is predicated
on the company because they've got a lot
of hard work ahead of them and we're
trying to support them in that so how
then would you describe your
relationship with uber right now given
that to some extent they're trying to
compete with Google at least on the
driverless car front and some would say
mapping you know when a company gets to
any company gets to a certain kind of
breakout size they're gonna compete with
lots of things but whether it's Google
Facebook are there companies in our
portfolio of investments and that's not
a surprise to us that that happens and
and when we first met with Travis the
the idea of a self-driving car existed
so so no one is shocked by by this
development and and you know we're
investors in uber so we're big believers
in in Travis and that team and we have
lots of friends that work there so we
really would like to see them succeed
now I would love to get your thoughts on
the environment right now are you seeing
more down round
out there where are we in this sort of
funding supercycle this is this is when
investing in startups becomes a
spectator sport
that's when I start to worry about
things and I lived through 1999 and 2000
when it started to become a real
spectator sport and I think we're kind
of into that area again and I think 99
to 2000 was a period where companies
that had no business going public we're
going public much too soon and now we're
in an era where the pendulum has swung
the other way where companies that
probably should go public or ready to go
public are waiting much longer than
maybe they should in some cases and it's
just a matter of time before the
pendulum swings back the other way as
well so what does that look like and
what are the biggest warning signs out
there that you're seeing I think it
looks like you know you have these these
billion dollar-plus valuation companies
some of which will do really well and be
the foundational companies technology
companies of the future and and some
that won't do very well because it
wasn't the right time or the people
worked hard and it didn't work out and
and because the valuations are high and
they get a lot of attention when when
they don't succeed they'll probably get
a lot of attention as well and so when
people ask the bubble question in to me
what they really mean is is someone
about to lose a lot of money and at
those valuations when companies don't
succeed there is money to be lost and
it's just it's part of the startup
lifecycle and so again none of that is
really surprising to me I just think
it's part of the business cycle that
we're in